[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france 24 se
cumplieron 150 años desde el nacimiento
de maría montessori la italiana que creó
el revolucionario método de enseñanza
montessori vigente hasta nuestros días
es además considerada una de las
primeras voces del feminismo hoy en día
está entre las mujeres más admiradas de
la historia por una fuerte oposición a
la violencia y a la represión sobre su
legado y sobre su historia que no está
exenta de situaciones contradictorias
hablaremos hoy
el método de enseñanza de maría
montessori bautizado con su nombre la
mantiene 150 años después como una de
las mujeres más admiradas de la historia
es un referente educativo pero también
de feminismo veamos
nunca ayudes a un niño mientras está
realizando una tarea en la que siente
que puede tener éxito era uno de los
lemas de mariah tecla artemisia
montessori recordada como una mujer
cosmopolita y opuesta a la violencia una
apasionada de las matemáticas que se
convirtió en la tercera italiana en
graduarse en medicina y fue candidata
tres veces al premio nobel de paz y es
que en su método escolar no represivo
prevalece en la libertad y la dedicación
a los mismos estuvo plenamente
comprometida en las luchas feministas e
invitó a las mujeres a apasionarse de la
ciencia un día la mujer se casara y
tendrá hijos por elección y no porque el
matrimonio y la maternidad se le
impongan su vida no fue fácil producto
de una relación fuera del matrimonio con
giuseppe ferrucio uno de los fundadores
de la neuropsiquiatría infantil en
italia tuvo un hijo mario a quien
entregó en acogida a una familia de
tivoli hasta que fue a buscarlo cuando
cumplió 15 años y pasó el resto de su
vida con él en 1907 montessori creó la
primera casa de los niños en el barrio
de san lorenzo de roma' un lugar con una
alta mortalidad infantil y por eso
allí comenzó a aplicar su método
educativo que es el más admirado
adoptado e imitado en todo el mundo ella
misma viajó por muchos países abriendo
escuelas las ideas de su revolución son
simples hay que confiar en el niño no
debe ser agobiado o forzado se debe dar
espacio a su espontaneidad sentirse
libre en un entorno donde todo espacios
muebles objetos juegos están hechos a
medida el maestro explica brevemente
observa y sin interferir
al menos unos 65 mil escuelas de
guarderías y de educación infantil en
todo el mundo utilizan hoy el método
montessori esa vigencia y la figura de
montessori alrededor del tema es de lo
que vamos a hablar hoy y para eso está
con nosotros
berta sarmiento bautista ella es
pedagoga de la universidad pedagógica
nacional de colombia desde bogotá la
saludo bienvenida a berta gracias por
estar con nosotros en ellas hoy
muchas gracias por la invitación verdad
quiero empezar preguntándole lo
necesario montessori afecto y aún hoy
afecta la vida de millones de personas
es una herencia de más de un siglo la
que nos deja porque hoy el método
montessori sigue siendo tan relevante
bueno hoy más que nunca porque
justamente en este contexto de
confinamiento hay un movimiento de más
de 350 madres de familia que lo están
usando en su casa que lo están haciendo
los cursos online que lo están poniendo
en práctica es decir el momento de
confinamiento en donde las madres se
están volviendo educadoras de la
libertad y de la responsabilidad del
propio aprendizaje que era el lema de
maría montessori entonces este es un
método que par que está pasando de la
escuela a la escuela hogar en este
momento bueno y cuáles son esas
características que hacen este modelo o
este método tan especial cómo se educan
los niños bajo una tendencia con
montessori
bueno primero a ella no le gustaba mucho
que se hablar varios métodos porque para
ella era una filosofía de vida una
convicción
que partía de tres principios la
libertad por encima de todo respetar la
libertad del niño la libertad de
movimiento la libertad de elección de lo
que a él le regresaría a conocer en
segundo lugar es una educación para la
paz fue
es más lo mencionó ahorita en tres
ocasiones fue nominada al premio nobel
de paz esos últimos años de vida tuvo
mucho contacto por ejemplo con gandhi
hablando de la no-violencia y pues en la
metodología propiamente está el cambiar
por completo del aula escolar y diseñar
lo que se llama un ambiente preparado
para para que el niño necesita la
libertad de movimiento quita los
pupitres digamos que en eso se
inspiraría no y enviarán las las
bibliotecas lúdicas que hay son partes y
das a lo que proponía el espacio abierto
con muebles al alcance de los niños con
mesas ergonómicas y en proporción a la
estatura de los niños en donde ellos
tengan libertad para
elegir y demás pero no se trataba
tampoco de que no dejará las cosas
tiradas no había un principio de
libertad pero también con
responsabilidad en el niño usa los todo
el material pero lo tiene cuando lo deja
de usar tiene que volverlo a dejar
organizadamente en el ambiente preparado
por el principio de orden externo le
ayuda al niño a organizar su pensamiento
a hacer un orden interno el tercer
principio no pues es que el rol del
maestro no es el de un estudiante sino
el de un guía él es el puente entre el
niño y ese espacio enorme que él va a
explorar y que quiere conocer y pues el
cuarto el más importante e inclusive dio
pie a lo que es la pedagogía científica
ese es el estudio de lo que ella llama
los cuatro planos del desarrollo del
niño que más tarde quince años más tarde
el umpire va a retomar
a profundizar del punto de vista del
desarrollo de la lógica pero ella ya
tomó los cuatro plazos digamos el primer
plano ya lo denominaba la mente
absorbente de los 0 a los 6 años el
segundo plano la niñez en donde en donde
el niño
se vuelve cósmico quiere saber todo de
la naturaleza del cosmos de la vida se
abre a un aprendizaje sin límites se
llama la escuela cósmica el de la
adolescencia de los 12 a los 18 años y
el de la madurez de los 18 a los 24
digamos habría cuatro lemas que los
caracteres harían en la niñez la
infancia el niño dice ayúdame a hacerlo
por mí mismo aprendí a hacer las cosas
biológica y física médico de los 6 a los
2 se dice le dice el niño al traductor
ayúdame a pensar por mí mismo
ventana dolencia si ya terminó la ayuda
de aprendizaje contigo y en la madurez
ya te va a decir que puede ayudar bueno
le quería preguntar también por otro
aspecto muy importante y es que claro
ella dedicó su vida a los niños y se
volvió una figura mundialmente famosa
pero hoy en día también la reconocemos
como una voz temprana del feminismo
cuando esa palabra ni siquiera estaba en
el vocabulario de las personas háblenos
un poco de esa faceta que a través de la
educación la convirtió en una figura
prominente por las mujeres
bueno ella fue una mujer de un
temperamento muy fuerte muy firme de era
una mujer que desobediente de lo
contrario no hubiera podido romper
paradigmas ella creía por encima de todo
en sus convicciones
desafortunadamente o afortunadamente no
sé esa relación con su profesor de
neuropsiquiatría de psiquiatría médica
que la llevó a tener un hijo con él no
es que lo hubiera tenido por fuera del
matrimonio él se casa después con la
mujer que le impone la madre de él pero
ya estaba embarazada mariah
esto le marcó la la vida no es que ella
hubiese dejado por con rita propia de
ese hijo a una familia sino que el
equipo de ese niño y se lo entregó a una
familia que dependían por completo
económicamente de la lucha de ella en
primer lugar fue por el derecho a ser
madre en ese momento pues
digamos la fuerza de los prejuicios
sociales era muy amplia y pues
si ella no hubiera hecho lo que hizo no
hubiera podido tampoco desarrollarse
profesionalmente y también se habría
manchado la profesión de como médico
siquiatra sin embargo ella de dato todo
el amor a su hijo pelea por él
tiene una postura muy personal digamos
desde las primeras mujeres que
consideran que el matrimonio no se
impone porque pues en esa época se hacía
por la madre elegía cuál era la mujer de
mayor conveniencia para el hijo y
entonces y rechaza fue muy rechazada
porque consideraban que ella al ser una
mujer tan inteligente y tan preparada de
estar haciendo competencia de estar
haciendo sombra a su propio propio
esposo ya invita a las mujeres a
desarrollar su pensamiento a la
ineficiencia a la autonomía a la
libertad
pues muchas gracias por este recorrido
tan sabe tan tan bonito y por qué no
decirlo tan educativo que nos da por la
vida de maría montessori y habría que
decirlo también cómo se parece la
realidad que vivió en su momento esta
italiana con cosas que hoy en día
muchísimas décadas después todavía están
ocurriendo maría montessori nos abrió
camino como mujeres profesoras
un detalle a ver quién en esa época
podría oponerse a benito mussolini
era muy difícil ella es invitada por
benito mussolini a formar unos guías
unos pedagogos guías de la escuela pero
él quería que fuera los niños para
cuando ella se da cuenta que esos días
son militares y que lo que quería benito
mussolini era que forma la gente
obediente ella se rebela contra él ella
hace una denuncia pública y hace una
marcha feminista en contra del fascismo
claro que sí es que tiene una vigencia
total siempre 50 años o 130 años después
tiene una vigencia total hoy en día por
los cambios de mentalidad son los más
largos de curar mientras no lo he haba
en digamos con un rayo láser los cambios
mentales es la mentalidad de la gente
sobre todo en los aspectos de autonomía
o para bailes pop popular
pues profesora se nos acaba el tiempo
pero muchísimas gracias por haber estado
con nosotros y por darnos este paseo por
una vida que hoy en día merece todo el
reconocimiento y pues que estamos
poniendo muchas madres la vida de
nuestros hijos y la educación de
nuestros hijos aún en sus ideas y en su
filosofía que tenga un feliz día
gracias muy amables a nuestros
televidentes continúen con france24
volvemos próximamente en ellas hoy
[Música]